[MUSIC PLAYING]
JONATHAN CHEUNG: Hi.
I'm Jonathan Cheung, tech lead
on the Google Play Console
working on go-to-market tools.
And I'm here today with
my colleagues, Ignacio,
on the Play business
development team,
and David, product
manager on Play Console.
We're excited to talk to you
about what Play Console tools
you can take advantage of
when building and managing
your games.
Fact-- in the last few years,
the number of Android players
who have installed a game
has more than doubled.
Players from all
around the world
and from all
different backgrounds
are enjoying an unprecedented
amount of new gameplay
experiences on Android.
As game developers, this
is your chance, your chance
to build new experiences,
to connect to more players,
and to find success
in the market.
Whether you're a new developer
building your first game
or a seasoned veteran
of the industry,
the opportunity
is yours to grasp.
That being said,
with opportunity
comes a degree of risk.
Games development on mobile
is an ever changing landscape,
and player expectations
of mobile games
has never been higher.
There's more competition than
ever before in the marketplace.
There are already one million
games live on the Play Store,
and new games are launching
all the time on Google Play.
Development costs are increasing
due to the demands of a higher
fidelity on mobile games.
And consumers are expecting
more feature-rich experiences
on mobile.
Finally, marketing games is
getting increasingly more
difficult. Use
acquisition spending
is increasing, as developers
are moving towards fewer, larger
launches in a single year.
At Google Play, we
understand these problems
and want to help you where we
can to bring as much success
as possible to your games.
We are committed
to building tools
to help you plan and
de-risk your launches
and to help you maintain
and support your games
after a successful launch.
Let us take you on a journey
from pre to post-launch, which
will hopefully provide
some insights into some
of the exciting tools we
have available for you.
We will be covering
some existing tools,
share some interesting
anecdotes and best practices,
and show off some
new tools, which
we feel will help you
on your road to success.
First, pre-launch.
This phase is critical
for making sure
you are delivering the right
experience for your players,
whether that be in the
gameplay experience
itself, the stability and
performance of your game,
or in the content
roadmap you have planned.
We're going to be going
through some areas of focus
during pre-launch
and also walk through
some of these tools we feel
are helpful at this stage.
First, and perhaps most
importantly, testing.
It is crucial to get your
testing strategy right
when launching a new game.
As you know, launching
and maintaining games
is an expensive proposition.
It is critical to make
sure that, when you launch
your product, it will
be stable and bug free,
resonate with your players
from a game play perspective,
and have a sustainable roadmap
to keep your players invested
in your game.
Internal testing allows you
to publish and distribute
your APKs in seconds,
instead of hours,
so you can push your
daily builds to your team
immediately.
It also features
integrations with our API
and other third-party
plugins, such as Gradle.
Finally, it benefits from
all the Google Play products
you've come to love, such as
in-app product support, country
targeting, LVL, and of course,
the newly announced Android app
bundle.
Developers are
using this new track
to do rapid, iterative testing
for launching new games,
as well as for adding
features to existing games.
For instance, using it to push
the daily builds to QA in order
to make sure the releases
meet their bar for quality,
or using it to push experimental
builds to a group of friends
and colleagues in order to play
test new gameplay mechanics.
Here are some things
to think about when
using internal testing.
Its a great opportunity to
focus on stability and bugs
in order to judge every release
against your bar for quality.
If possible, it can also
be useful to start testing
on a wide variety of
devices so that, when
you decide to roll
out to more players,
you can be certain they will
receive the quality gameplay
experience that you will
want them to receive.
One of our most used
feature for game developers
is closed testing.
Closed testing is
a great opportunity
to build a tight-knit
community of testers
who will be able to provide
you with valuable feedback
before and after launch.
Users can be invited directly
from the Play Console,
using email lists
or Google Groups.
They can then opt-in via web
app, as shown in this picture.
Once opted in, they can
install the game directly
from the Play Store.
Over 60% of game developers on
Play already use this feature
and have found great
success with it.
Let's take a quick
look at a case study.
BRAVOCO, with the game,
"Forces of Freedom",
really took to
heart the philosophy
of building a strong tester
community for their closed
test.
They focus on recruiting
the right sort of players,
even reaching beyond the
usual online communities
to find the sort
of player they felt
would have affinity with the
theme of their game, which
is a military shooter game.
As you can see in this picture,
they went to this airsoft event
and recruited players
on-site to play their game.
During the testing
period, BRAVOCO
made sure that they
were available 24/7
via social media, and
especially instant messaging.
This allowed them
not only to gather
very specific valuable
feedback, but also
to build connections
with individual testers
of their game.
This dedication to building
a strong test community
paid off dividends
both during testing
and even after launch
and early access where
"Forces of Freedom" has
now attracted more than 10
million players and counting.
In conclusion, here
are some things
to think about when
using closed testing.
Create a strong and
diverse tester community.
Remember, these players
will be critical in shaping
the initial direction
of your game.
Experiment with new gameplay
mechanics and content.
Don't be afraid of
negative feedback.
Remember, your
ratings and reviews
are still not live
at this point.
And finally, think
about reaching out
to your tester community to
gather very specific feedback.
This is your chance to ask them
what works, what didn't work,
and how do we improve.
Next, open testing.
Once a game is technically solid
and your main gameplay hooks
are built in, it's time
to think about expanding
your test to more
players in preparation
for your big launch.
Open testing allows your game to
be discoverable and installable
on the Play Store
and for players,
after a developer defined
cap, to opt in and install
your game.
Players won't be able to leave
ratings until the game fully
launches, but can provide
anonymous feedback
to the developer at any time.
Open testing comes
in two flavors,
depending on the
state of your game.
If you don't have a
production release already,
or in the same country as
you are running your test in,
users will be able to
install your game directly
from the Play Store
without needing to opt in.
We call this early access.
Your game will be
tagged as unreleased,
as shown in this image.
If you have a production
release already--
for instance, you may have soft
launched in the same country--
you can still continue
to use open testing.
Existing users will continue to
get updates on the test track,
and new users can opt in via
a console provided web link
or through the card, which
is shown on the screen
here at the bottom of
the game's details page.
Players opted into an
open test in this state
will see the game
tagged as Beta.
So bringing together
these forms of testing,
of internal tests and closed
tests, you, as the developers,
have control over who can
install and play your game.
Early access tests
can be installed
and discovered directly
from the Play Store
and are a great way to
expand your tester base,
as well as building hype
around your big launch.
Finally, open tests can be
used to continue testing
with a wide audience, even
after your production release.
Utilize these testers to try
out new features and tweaks
to your game before rolling
out to all your players.
Moving on-- pre-launch
reports can also
help developers iron out
quality and performance issues
prior to launch.
Whenever a test APK is uploaded
and nondeterministic bot
will crawl your game
while it's running
on a real physical device
in one of our test labs.
Game developers have
found a lot of value
in the pre-launch report.
90% of developers don't
push to production
if the report shows issues.
Demo loops goes even
further for game developers.
Record and upload a game demo
loop using Firebase test lab
and receive a PLR report on
crash and performance metrics,
including the all important
frames per second.
This allows you to discover
rendering issues even faster
and launch with
greater confidence.
Half Brick Games, the
developers of titles
such as "Fruit Ninja"
and "Jetpack Joyride"
have found great
values in demo loops.
They've evolved
their QA processes
around using PLR
demo loops, as it
allows them to check for
visual glitches, crashes,
and performance, among
many other things.
They rely on the fact that
PLR will automatically
run on a wide range of
devices and device specs
for every test release.
So how did they do this?
Their new game, which
is "Endless Runner",
has a built-in
replay functionality
which are used to record and
save interesting game runs.
With a few simple
lines of code, they
can instrument PLR demo loops to
run on these recorded sessions.
Whereas before, it was
a very manual process
to kick off their benchmarking,
now, with PLR demo loops,
it's automated for them
for every test release.
They can look at these
metrics and compare them
to every previous
release to make sure
that their game has no
regressions in terms
of performance.
Before we move
over to launching,
another important
aspect of pre-launch
is to plan your
strategy around content.
As such, don't be afraid to
test longer and to test earlier.
Consider using longer term
metrics, like D14 and D30,
in order to predict
future success.
Measure the rate of content
consumption during your testing
phase.
This can be useful
for planning ahead,
so that you have enough
content for your players
when you launch until
your first big update.
Also, this phase is
a great opportunity
to test what sort
of LiveOp events
will resonate with
your player base,
so that you can create the
content your players will
want to receive.
It is also important to consider
how different forms of testing
can be used to achieve
different purposes.
All testing tracks can be used
in unison with each other,
allowing you to target
different experiences
to different groups of testers.
For instance, you
may want to consider
to run your daily builds past
your internal test track users
to check for regressions
at the same time
as you're running a large scale
open test with early access.
Closed testing can also be used
to fine tune specific gameplay
mechanics with a select
audience before rolling out
to your production users.
Finally, you should
always keep in mind
that mobile games development
is an ever-changing landscape.
New technology is opening
up new ways to play,
and player expectations on
mobile are ever changing.
Remember to continuously
evaluate your processes
around development and testing.
See what works,
what doesn't work.
And most importantly, do
not be afraid of change.
With that, I would
like to hand over
to Ignacio, who's going to talk
to you about launching games
on Google Play.
[APPLAUSE]
IGNACIO MONEREO:
Thanks, Jonathan.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Ignacio.
I'm part of the Play
team based in London.
And I have the
privilege and honor
to work with many game
developers, like you.
So let's talk about
launching your game.
I'm pretty sure that, by now,
you have tested and tested
your game.
And you are 100% confident,
or let's say at least 95%
confident, that your game is
ready both from the backend
and frontend to
receive a lot of users.
That as well, your
customer teams
are ready to manage
the community,
create new live events,
or deal with the feedback.
But above all, that your
game is lots of fun.
And so you have a launch date.
And it's still is scary, right?
So we are lucky in the Play
team, in the Play Console,
you have some tools that
will help you to reach
those levels of confidence.
And today, for the large part,
we're going to talk about three
in particular.
We're going to talk
about Device Catalog.
about preregistration,
and then last,
country targeting.
Let's look at them
in further detail.
So device catalog-- this
feature, it's very popular.
And the reason is because it
helps you make better decisions
when prioritizing back fixes and
delivering the right experience
for each device.
Since launch last year, we have
seen that 66% of developers
are using it on a monthly basis.
We all know that Android is
an incredibly rich ecosystem
with hundreds of manufacturers
and thousands of devices.
So let's turn these
into an opportunity
and try to deliver the
best experience based
on relevant factors such
as SOC, RAM, or CPU.
But during this process, there's
one key thing to remember,
which is essentially
to think big.
And what I mean by
think big is just
let's try to include as many
devices by default as possible.
Excluding devices should
be a temporary measure
until some of these
bugs are fixed.
Let's look at the
device detail page.
The device detail
page is a feature
that allows you to
review individually
thousands of devices,
identify relevant criteria,
such as RAM, SOC, or CPU.
Since last year, we've
added new filtering methods,
so for example, the screen size,
density, and application binary
interface.
As well, since last year, we
added the unsupported reason.
So you can very quickly
identify why a device
isn't supported by your game.
Lastly, I wanted
to highlight also
some interesting information
that the device detail
page is providing--
essentially, the number
of active devices
in this particular game,
the average rating,
and the revenues generated
by inner purchases
or subscriptions
in the last month.
So what some of the developers
are saying about this.
So Digital Legends, a mobile
developer from Barcelona,
they actually launched a very
popular game, "Respawnables",
which was launched in 2014.
And since then, they have seen
more than 30 million installs,
and what is more important,
more than 2 billion battles
played by the players.
So Digital Legends, two
or three times a week,
they check the device catalog.
And essentially,
they do three things.
The first one, they
exclude those devices
that do not meet the minimum
requirements in order
to deliver a great
user experience.
Then second, they
isolate the bugs.
And then third, they prioritize
device support and, as well,
these bug fixes.
So thanks to this
feature, Digital Legends
has seen an increase in the
user experience and ratings,
as well on the overall quality
and performance of the game.
So in conclusion, I wanted
to highlight three things
to remember.
So the first one, think big,
and support as many devices
as possible.
Second, if we have to
exclude some devices,
try to do it in a temporary way,
so we can fix all those bugs
and increase our chances
to reach a bigger audience.
And then last, use
the device detail page
to get very relevant
information, such as,
for example, the unsupported
reason, or the average revenues
or average rating.
And with this, let's move
onto the next functionality
feature--
preregistration.
We all know that, in
gaming, creating excitement
before even launch
is increasingly
critical and popular.
So the preregistration
feature has two benefits.
As a player, it's clear.
You can pre-register, and then
when the game is launched,
you will receive a notification
to install the game.
We all know that in certain
type of games, multiplayer,
social games, competitive
games in general,
it's critical to get
on early into the game.
However, from a
developer perspective,
I can see that there's
two main benefits here.
The first one is you can start
marketing early and capture
the audience interest.
As well, by monitoring
the pre-reg count,
we have an indication of the
influx of users at launch.
And we can plan ahead not
only from a server side,
but also like marketing.
So let's look at a case study.
Nexon is a Korean
developer and the creator
of some popular games, in
particular "Durango Wild
Lands", which was
launched in Korea the 25th
of January, 2018.
So they started
the pre-reg process
six weeks before
launching the game.
And during this time, they saw
2.5 million preregistration
users.
Out of those 2.5 million
users, pre-reg users,
46% were coming from the Play
pre-registration feature.
And what is very
interesting here
is that the day
seven conversion,
meaning from launch date
until the day seven,
the first week, the conversion
for Play pre-reg users
was about 70%, which
is seven times higher
than the other sources.
So as Kiki [? Heelman, ?] the
head of platform relations
says, "Google preregistration
is essentially a very effective
marketing tool."
So how is Nexon using
for other games?
So Nexon has launched
20 games in 2017
and has used the
pre-registration feature
in 10 games last year.
They saw a 50% conversion
from pre-reg users
to actual users
downloading this game.
They have seen also that
the CPIs are quite lower.
They're 60% lower in pre-launch
than in post-lunch period.
And as such, this has led
to a decision to allocate
the marketing budget 50%
to the pre-launch state ,
rather than in post-launch.
So far, the preregistration
pilot has been very successful.
In 2017, we've seen numbers,
such as more than 50 developers
using this
functionality, as well,
200 million players registering,
and 100 million players
actually downloading
those games, and then
a total of 400 launches across
both small and big developers.
Indeed, this is exciting.
But what is even more
exciting is to know that,
today, we are
announcing that pre-reg
is becoming available to
all developers very soon.
So what are some of
the things that we
need to take into account
if we want to have
a good experience with pre-reg?
So three things, as well,
that I wanted to remember.
So the first is allow some
time to build excitement.
So in between three
to six weeks is enough
in order to gather all
this audience interest.
But as well, use
all the channels
that you have available in
order to build that excitement,
for example, media, communities,
forums, your own website.
And across all
these channels, make
sure that you have
a clear action--
in this case, preregister
in Google Play.
With this in mind, let's
jump into the last tool,
which is country targeting.
Country targeting is
a very powerful tool.
And essentially, it
allows two things.
So first, we can have
different tracks per country.
And then we can run
separate closed, open tests
or production in a
specific geography.
This is very useful
as the quote mentions,
for soft launching processes.
Where for example, we want
to have one particular region
in production to test user
acquisition or monetization.
Secondly, it's key during
launch because we can use
a staged rollout per geography.
And this means that
you can control
the rollout in
different countries,
and then monitor which users
are getting into the app.
This allows us to test server
performance or user feedback.
So let's look at how
some developers are
using this functionality.
So Wargaming, Ukrainian
developer and behind the game
"World of Warships Blitz",
they launched this game
in January, 2018, as well.
And the game has already seen
more than 3 million installs
in Google Play.
By the way, 100
million ships destroyed
and more than 15 million
planes shot down.
So incredible numbers,
as well, on that side.
And we spoke with
Raymond Cheung,
who is the marketing
manager in Wargaming.
And he told us that they
used the country targeting
during the soft launch period.
This soft launch period
took about six months,
and they divided
it in three stages.
So the first stage, they select
a few number of countries.
And they were testing
things like stability--
so crash rates, monetization,
lifetime value, and CPI--
and then engagement, which is
user engagement and duration
of the games.
On the second stage, they opened
up to a few more countries,
and they were testing
mostly server capacity
and ensuring the
stability of the game.
And then on the
third stage, they
opened up to already
more countries
across all continents with the
intent of testing monetization,
mostly.
So lastly during
this whole process,
Wargaming was testing,
as well, and monitoring
the ratings and the
reviews and reacting
based on the user feedback.
So in conclusion, regarding
country targeting,
two things to remember today.
So the first one is like we
can use country targeting
during soft launch, but also
during the open and closed
Beta test processes, as well as
during even like future updates
or post-launch period.
And the second
thing is, at launch,
plan ahead what is
going to be the rollout
to the different countries.
So [INAUDIBLE] all the
work, and download the game,
and enjoy it quickly,
but without any issues.
And with this, I would like
to call my colleague, David.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID WIESENFELD:
Thanks, Ignacio.
I'm David, product manager on
Play Console Go To Market Tools
and Google Play Games Services.
Now we're moving
on to post-launch.
At this point, you've
developed your game, tested it
with a growing
cohort of testers,
had a good launch day
and a strong launch week,
and the dust is settling.
What are the things
that you're going
to be thinking about next?
Three post-launch activities
that we're going to focus on
are growing your audience to
get as many people as possible
playing your great
game, engaging
your players by delivering a
great experience that they want
to keep coming back
to, and earning money
so you can keep running your
game or build your next one.
Let's start with
audience growth.
Players are becoming harder
and more expensive to acquire
and retain.
Game developers
like you are using
lots of different
strategies to acquire users.
UA is common, but so are
other less trackable methods--
cross-promotion in other games,
leveraging YouTube influencers,
utilizing social channels,
third-party website marketing.
And I'm sure you have
other great methods too.
You can track clicks
and installs from ads.
But players who install your
app organically from the Play
Store who may get there,
say, via search after reading
about your game on a
third-party website
are a black box while accounting
for the majority of installs
for most developers.
Using the new tools in Organic
Acquisition Insights report
in Play Console, you can
now see the breakdown
of how many new
installers have accessed
your listing either via search
or by browsing the Play Store.
Most users find games in
Google Play using search.
And with this tool, you
can dive deeper into search
and see the specific
search terms
that drive users to your game.
Organic Acquisition
Insights reports
is coming soon for
all developers.
The developers
we've talked to are
excited to use these
insights in order
to assess the
acquisition strategies,
change their store
listing and screenshot
to reflect what their
users are looking for,
and even optimize
in-app onboarding
experiences to ensure that
it references the features
and benefits that the
users find most appealing.
This is a powerful new tool
that I hope you'll explore.
To find out more about
Organic Acquisition Insights,
you can go to this
talk tomorrow morning.
Next, we'll talk about
Google Play Instant.
Growing your game involves
getting users excited about it.
And a great way to do that is to
give them a quick and easy way
to experience it.
For quick background, we
launched Instant Apps at I/O
last year.
And since then,
we've been very busy.
There are more than
a billion devices
that support Instant Apps.
And we've improved our
tooling to make building
Instant Apps even easier.
And as you may have
heard, we announced
that we're bringing Instant Apps
to games at GDC six weeks ago.
And as of today,
Google Play Instant
is now available to
all game developers.
So why should you consider
making an instant game?
Instant games allow players to
try your game before installing
it and make it easy to
install the full game
at the end of the instant
game experience using
the install prompt API.
Being able to try a
game before installing
is a hit with players.
And after publishing
their Instant game,
Mighty Battles has seen a 19%
increase in acquisition rate.
So what's the difference between
Instant Apps and Instant Games?
What we've done is adapt
the Instant App frameworks
so it better meets the needs
of game developers like you.
There are three
things we've changed.
We've increased the size
limit to 10 megabytes.
We've enabled
progressive download
of executable code and assets
using the [INAUDIBLE] API.
And very importantly,
we've added full support
for native code
and are integrating
with game engines and Open GL.
This means you can
use the same codebase
and tools as your full game
to build your instant game.
And by creating an instant game,
you open up a lot of surfaces.
Players can experience instant
games directly from ads,
in the Play Games app
arcade, via a link you
can send with a messaging
app, and of course,
in the Play Store.
While we're on the topic
of Google Play Instant,
we need to touch back just for
a moment on launching tools.
Pre-reg is a very
successful program.
And we're bringing
the Instant games
to Play Store's
preregistration feature.
Now players that
preregister can get
a sneak preview of your game.
And when you promote
preregistration
through social media,
email, or on your website,
users will be able
to play instantly
from any Android device.
It's an awesome way to introduce
your game to the world.
To learn more about
Instant games,
you can attend this
session on Thursday.
Next, we'll look at engagement.
Android Vitals is designed
to help you identify issues
at scale so you can create
a better, more fluid, more
optimized, and more engaging
experience for your players.
There are a number of new
vitals features launching,
including benchmarks
for all vitals,
and new vitals, including
startup time, which
were discussed in the
Android Vital session
earlier this afternoon.
Of particular interest
for game developers
like you, are stability
and battery vitals.
Stability vitals include
A and R's and crashes.
And batteries include stuck wake
locks and excessive wakeups.
We're now showing these
vitals against a bad behavior
threshold.
Exhibiting bad
behavior in vitals
will negatively affect the
user experience in your game
and can result in bad ratings
and poor discoverability
in the Play Store.
We also have vitals for
rendering and startup time,
though, these are
informative at this point.
And with the new
vitals benchmarks,
you can see how you stack
up against similar games.
It's important to know
that Android Vitals is
a powerful tool not
just for app developers,
but for game developers too.
Using Vitals, game
developer, Kiloo,
whose game "Subway Surfers"
just passed 1 billion installs
on Google Play, was able to make
drastic improvements to their A
and R rate, reducing it from
around 2% to below 0.1%.
So to help you ensure your
users enjoy playing your game,
how should you be thinking
about using Vitals in your day
to day?
Keep an eye on A and
R's, crashes, wake locks,
and wake ups, which will be
easier with the notifications
and alerts built
into Play Console.
And use the Vitals dashboard
as part of your toolkit
to chase down problems.
Now, we wanted to share
with you something
we've been working on.
It's not ready for
general consumption yet.
That's coming.
But we're excited to be working
to bring LiveOps to play.
We are creating new
experiences in the store
and in the Play Games
app to show players
the events that are
happening now in their games.
This is proving very
popular with players,
and we're going to continue
exploring in this direction.
And finally, let's
move on to revenue.
Google Play has had
subscriptions since 2012,
but they've mostly been
the domain of subscription
for access apps.
Games typically monetize through
IAPs in ads or are paid games.
But a number of developers
have been experimenting
with subscriptions,
and we wanted
to share their experiences.
You may be wondering,
what's the business case
of adding subscriptions
when I already have IAP?
Developers who
implement subscriptions
report an increase in
engagement and retention
not just for the subscribers,
but for their overall user
base, as well, as you can
see from Monster Strike's
experience with "MonPass."
Many, including Scopely, also
notice minimal cannibalization
of IAP, resulting
in incremental gains
to overall revenue driven by
both subscriptions and IAP.
Another developer who's found
successful subscriptions
is Network in "Legendary
Game of Heroes."
They use subscriptions for
their VIP loyalty program.
This program has proved popular
with players, as you can see,
and had created a
new revenue stream
for "Legendary Game of Heroes"
with strong positive impact
on overall revenue.
There are two best practices
in using subscriptions
to provide value to players--
loyalty programs for your high
value users and a new access
point to premium experience
for traditional non-buyers.
The target audience
will influence how you
choose to design your offering.
Some examples of a
VIP loyalty program
features include exclusive
or early access to content,
special in-game VIP status
and title, or a bonus
payout with each purchase.
This is the most popular
subscription design
we've seen so far
and, as you can
see from Ludia's "Jurassic
World, The Game,"
implement here.
Developers have also
found that subscriptions
can be effective in converting
traditional non-buyers.
These players are motivated by
getting a good financial deal.
You can see Network's
implementation here,
which is a VIP
loyalty program aimed
at these traditional non-buyers.
Of course, as with any
monetization system,
be aware of potential downsides.
And keep a close pulse of
player feedback and community
sentiment.
To help you with your
subscription program,
Google Play has a very robust
subscriptions infrastructure
with a lot of rich features.
We support you with billing
tools and analytics insight
reports throughout the
entire user funnel.
And we can take care of
useful subscription features,
such as flexible billing,
free trials, account hold,
so that you can focus on
testing and implementing
an effective in-game
subscription design.
To learn more about
subscriptions,
you can watch the
recording of this session
from earlier this afternoon.
We've gone through
some of the tools
that you can take
advantage of post-launch.
But as we draw to
a close, I want
to loop us back to the
beginning of our talk
and call out testing again.
It's good to always be testing.
In comparison to apps, this
can be tricky for games,
as some games need users
to be on the same version
to function properly.
But think about how you can
effectively use Play's testing
tracks, which will all work
as well post-launch as they
do pre-launch, to
ensure your updates
live up to the quality
bar set for your game.
To wrap up, we've
discussed a number
of tools in Play
Console you can use
in various stages of
your game's lifecycle.
There's a lot going
on in mobile gaming
right now with
fantastic gamer growth,
loads of high quality
games being released,
and lots of competition.
It's your own fault,
as you keep raising
the bar higher and higher
in terms of graphics, story,
and gameplay.
Well done.
We're excited to see what
you're able to build next
and where gaming goes from here.
The tools we've talked
you through today
can help you along your
journey in a few key places
and give you some abilities
and insights you can
leverage to help you succeed.
We'd also love to hear your
feedback on this session.
Thanks, for your time.
We're around for
the rest of the day.
And you can also check
out the sandbox over here.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]